while I was talking to the survivors and
hearing them saying that their voices
are not heard and there is nothing there
is no help there is no support there is
no status for them then basically I
thought how can I contribute
idea came off the skirts where we are
all as one and then a football pitch
kind of is a male-dominated playground
subsidiary so there is a test oh Emily
really epitome of effluent Annelle
failed the shock to our Eleuthera subsea
party on who not okay deployed but
partially children we're now known as
the land of rapes but did you ever
wonder how this took shape don't shy
away now you're a part of this culture
of lawyers who will kill in politics